the case for gamestonk is the story of
american greed
hubris and the power of collective and
leveraged stupidity
recently gamestop's whole world got
flipped upside down when an
army of gamblers who were bored because
vegas is shut down joined a
decentralized hedge fund called wall
street bets
and realized that the stock was way over
shorted
they pumped them hard and astronomers
are saying that tonight
if you go outside you can actually see
their ticker on the moon
but this massive success hasn't been met
without controversy
in response traditional hedge fund
managers everywhere are angry because
manipulating the stock market is only
legal when they do it when does this
become manipulation jim
gamestop is a company that historically
has had steadily declining revenues
which means they're a good target for
big hedge funds to short them
unfortunately for these billionaires who
are soon to be millionaires they
overlooked one thing
when you bet against wall street
sometimes wall street bets bets against
you
and so began the case for gamestonk
let's start with their slogan power to
the players
this is actually a metaphor for the
fundamental belief of gamestop
that the power should not be centralized
by giant mammoth companies who hold all
the power but rather
giving back to the people this resonated
with many people at wall street bets who
knew what it was like to be picked on
and ridiculed by billionaire hedge funds
every day they were laughed at for
yellowing their 401k into hertz
but who's laughing now the power balance
has shifted
you see billionaire hedge fund managers
overlooked a key component of shorting a
stock
stocks only go in the upward
direction it's crazy i know that they
don't teach this at wharton business
school but that's the kind of crazy
superstition
and mysticism that existed back then now
every 18 year old with a tick tock
account and robina knows better but it's
really
crazy to think of just how archaic this
way of fundamental investing
was and still is the other side of this
equation that many people aren't talking
about
is the case for in-person retailers like
gamestop
many people thought that with the rise
of online game purchases it'd be the end
of gamestop
but i know different there's a lot of
value in walking into gamestop and
smelling the soured mountain dew
and old carpet the annoying sales clerk
jeff and the garbage trade in value you
can't buy that with an online store
but these billionaires don't play video
games so they don't know that
another thing these boomers have never
heard of is the real fuel
of wall street bets something called a
meme
a meme is something that elon musk
tweets every few hours and gets fined by
the sec for
and recently the meme started flying
with such force that we might as well
rebuild spacex from the ground up the
only rockets we need
are already on the bird now many
analysts and anthropologists are already
looking at this event and calling it a
freak one-off an anomaly on wall street
but i know different they want to
believe that those are just
crazy predators being dumb but this is
so much more than that
this is a real life version of robin
hood
where a band of merry men steal from the
rich and give to the poor
this is a new world a brave world where
fundamental analysis doesn't hold us
down
all we need is the chart diamond hands
and the power
of 2.4 million raging bulls
that's the case for game stonk
[Music]
the